السكن بكام علشان شاب بيبقى لسه متخرج
وعايز يبدا حياته هيبدا منين هيجيب منين
ايه الاصل لما بيجي يشتري بيشتري على اساس
ان هو بيساعد يعني هو بيحفظ قيمه فلوسه
ويثبت سعر فانت لما تيجي تقولي لها اثبت
لك سعر الدولار يعني هيرفض فاحنا اقتراحنا
اقتراح ان احنا ممكن نقول ان هيبقى في
اجهزه دائما ان هو يكون دائما على مده
قصيره يمكن ثلاث سنين او اربع سنين ويكون
فيها السعر هو السعر العادي انما لو
العميل عايز اطول من كده فممكن يتحمل ايه
التغير في الاسعار نتيجه التضخم اللي ممكن
يحصل
يكون في تاثير والخوف ان هو يتبع ذلك بقى
ركود ركود نتيجه ان الغلاء الحاجه غليت
جدا والقدره الشرائيه كبد قلت بس هو فاضل
حاجه واحده بس اللي هي شغالين عليها اللي
هو العاملين بالخارج اللي هم متاثروش
بالاسعار
وتصدير العقار للدول الاجنبيه